we're being film because we're import
and we're in for good hey guys we're
gonna play pokemon go today this is my
Nets first time actually playing it I
got my shirt
never assembles Pokemon is someone to do
naughty things to my Pokemon not any
things
I like them to watch you need you knew
your things to myself just the Pokemon
and I alone let's go play it over you
know we look like we look like two
people trying to make a successful
YouTube video right here oh man there's
a Santa here I just got turn around real
fast
I miss Tony you're sitting at one of my
Sandshrew oh it bounced off Tony thanks
Tony
actually made a big difference son of a
[ __ ] pretty naughty things of this
guy's I think it's a good day all I
wanted to capture was one Pokemon at
least you know I believe in the one step
at a time
a SAN shoe gets the job done
tell you what next time a Pokemon
appears I'll let you capture ya gotta
catch em all gotta catch em all I used
to say the same thing about diseases hey
trying to catch [ __ ] Charmander here
you want your pizza let me have the
pizza no come on in Mexico came man
there's that bro c'mon there's a Help
Center might be able to find Pokemon at
the Help Center alright everyone's
looking at us through the window
what you're proposing on people looking
for Pokemon looking proposal - other
ideal they understand
where are all these things coming up
later you tap on
oh you're too far away but when you're
close to you spin it my pokeballs are
poaching so we can get her some
pokeballs yeah
we're gonna get something
some man we're doing really important
things right oh here you can capture it
sir sponsor what is it an abra an
average don't [ __ ] suck Tony you're
standing in front of the end go for it
we got an abra will be able to obtain
such an opera that's under cross cuts
that way here really you can't spin it
get spinning you're gonna get some
[ __ ] balls
you got tapped
I didn't tap any of them try again later
oh [ __ ] you car wash he defines the blue
tiled fountain I'm running low on
pokeballs it's pissing me off this game
brings out the worst in me where
dude you can do it do you think the
Napper is way over there or right here
in front of you come on it's jumping
yeah keeps jumping Smith dodges what do
you think you just gonna stand there
it's called the hunt capture your prey
you got the Abra
yeah yeah it's actually Tony's phone
because hers wasn't working so she got
Tony an abra I like walking at this kind
of pace kind of walking like my
character
it is another patters to found in places
here hold on is one less than want to
look right oh crap I got the Horatio
Biblica appreciate it got all the
pokéballs from it you should never trust
your best friend Mona
I know I'm your best friend
learn as fast France precept he really
spend a lot of time together
she considers me her best friend these
days it's pretty awesome of her I don't
really consider my best friend
obsession over REO it's a hospice center
I used to not believe in hospice centers
now I see they care
I'm a pokemon trainer
I got a gut tip Craig Alba Jim that's a
smell of sweat the Pokemon will be
sweating out once I'm done with them I
can't go to the gym until I reached
level five
now you're a free spirit you're gonna
lie you're like out of an independent
comedy as a pokemon trainer when you
have a partner you got to learn to work
with your partner communicate
communication is key often times
especially when I look the way I do
a woman is likely to fall in love with
said trainer that happens I must be
clear monnet
we are only working together to capture
Pokemon I don't want to be with
only for the Pokemon
okay if you insist
that's called good communication we've
searched for minutes from Pokemon let up
here why are we playing this
[ __ ] goddamn there's no Pokemon it's not
worth it not worth it
let's keep looking
I'm sure we'll be able to find one as
long as we keep looking we get by one
guys to get by one what works well one
more as you all know more it stop
whatever I want oh oh this is so
exhausting
there's no more the gone
there we going to be able to get to
level five at this rate
that really is a game of patience but
really is a way to teach us how to be
warriors out as much as worth training
the Pokemon the Pokemon are training us
as well to be persistent to not give up
in battle you don't want to Sandra's
what's up done with one wheel on the
next what do i do exactly
we're gonna head back home now one step
at a time
yeah you don't want to get a sore muscle
from all the exercise it's also weird
yeah more than just uh mentality it's
more than just a philosophy a way of
living being a pokemon trainer
they've also helped to really it does
hard out here you gotta take glucosamine
for the knees you don't want to get bad
joints from all the walking you do as a
trainer we're
we capture the most dangerous kind of
Pokemon no I'm now relax build up and
work up to it
Tiffany's today maybe 20 - okay thank
you guys
yeah subscribe to my channel
I'll have my phone with my belt along
here's what I'm gonna do
haven't been specific yet
let's just say it'll be a little bit of
its Mon champ